es braucht musik farben und papier
wenn der architekt peter zum tor seine
gebäude erträumt
[Musik]
alles beginnt mit einer freien zeichnung
einer fantastischen skizze der freiheit
eine welt zu entwerfen
[Musik]
so auch bei der therme falls dieser
meditation über die elemente wasser berg
und stein
am anfang war eine starke idee zum tor
hielt an ihr fest und erklärte sie auch
denen die später in ihr warten sollten
und dann dauert es drei jahre bis man
das übersetzt den architekten und
wirklich in eine kunst
eine kundin die künstlichkeit der
architektur und in die disziplin der
architektur disziplin müssen bei
zumthors unternehmungen vor allem die
handwerker aufbringen
sie sind es die seine visionen mit
strengster genauigkeit umzusetzen haben
der schmied mario waser gehört zu ihnen
bei der realisierung von peter zumthors
therme lastete auf ihm bei jedem
handgriff höchste verantwortung
erster halt einfach zum beispiel dass er
wirklich harnik gehren überraschung auf
der baustelle also ein mag nico und dem
gesetz gegen die amtsstuben oder gleich
als boni casinos handwerker müssen auf
augenhöhe sein
der meister verteidigt seine
künstlerische idee unterstützt diese
vision vor den widrigkeiten der realität
[Musik]
und tatsächlich
immer wieder sind es fantastische
projekte die zum tor der künstler
architekt sich vornimmt
gebäude die weit über das gewöhnliche
hinausgehen
auch exzentrisch und oft etwas entgegen
wie sein projekt in bardel einer insel
im nordosten norwegens hier errichtete
zum tor ein mahnmal in andenken an die
hexenverbrennungen im siebzehnten
jahrhundert unter schwierigen
klimatischen bedingungen
hier waren es deutsche handwerker aus
sachsen die zum tor fehlte und die
bereit waren sich auf den arbeitsstil
des hochdekorierten architekten aus
graubünden einzulassen
[Applaus]
schwierig ist das schön gewisse sachen
ausgelegt ist
das muss so sein das muss so sein das
muss so sein denn dann ist es schwierig
[Musik]
schwierig aber lohnenswert peter
zumthors porten haben eine magische
ausstrahlung
wer mitmachen will wenn sie wirklichkeit
werden muss bereit sein das unmögliche
möglich zu machen
[Musik]